laura ingraham of course host the ingram
angle right here she's a friend and
we're grateful to have her in our studio
tonight so Laura thanks a lot for coming
I thought as you're preparing for your
show tonight there's a big media angle
to this the press really drove a lot of
this behavior and drove this
investigation at Fox were allowed to say
by our network whatever we think is true
and they support us completely in that
I'm grateful for you watch the other
coverage and really it's just they're
reading every hours reading from the
same Maddow says clearly says what she
wants to say out everybody else seems to
be reading from some script that Jeff
Zucker wrote how implicated are these
channels in the travesty that we I think
the collusion between the media
apparatus the dominant media apparatus
other than Fox and the DNC the deep
state is profound and the international
elites who wanted this all to be true we
have to remember there's an
international angle here which you know
we're looking at the Ukraine angle and
all there's an international angle here
because Donald Trump came along and he
was the great disrupter on the scene yes
I don't buy into what you're doing at
the eeu god bless you I don't I don't
bind all your wine cellars and your Cohn
fabs and your think tanks and this whole
industry employs thousands and thousands
of people and Donald Trump said this
isn't working well for the United States
he was an existential threat to them
they cheered this whole thing on they
shell out the money for all these
conferences for people like Jon Meacham
who's I like Jon Meacham he's a really
talented writer but when someone like
Jon Meacham got caught up in this at
MSNBC I was looking at this he said you
know this is the very definition
basically of treason what Donald Trump
did he said his story this guy is like a
pillow surprise winning you know writer
when someone like that can get caught in
and snared in this frothy frenzy to get
Trump yes we have a big problem on our
hands and I am so glad I watched every
minute of your show tonight Tucker and
as I do every night but what you said
about the need for consequences and
repercussions it's just like with things
like Jesse Smollett or a UV a rape case
or what happened with the Cavanaugh
leaks there needs to be repercussions
either the public needs to you know
decide maybe we should
watch something else or there needs to
be a criminal investigation by bill bar
into how this all went down the FISA
warrants the the leaks that happen all
this stuff has to be looked at this
cannot happen to another president I
agree or a Democrat or a Republican I
don't care who you are
the criminalization of politics brought
down individuals who are caught up in
them in the gears and the machinery of
the prosecution complex in this country
but that's literally true so look people
call for my firing every day I'm not
calling Ted Allison your Stu I know I'm
saying don't think more slowly about
these issues no but I agree but I just
wonder and I'm so grateful to work here
I'm going to say that but I wonder how
can Jeff Zucker continue to run that
channel after what we just saw said they
brought in newly released people from
the government who would run our
agencies who clearly were getting
information about this investigation and
putting it on the air as propaganda it
turned out to be lies like how can you
do that and all that you know the I
think it's the Buddhists that the
fingers always pointed back at you so
everything they say about Trump's like
stay on TV colluding and the state-run
TV is like they're working for the deep
state or the elite state or whatever you
want to call it so they're all colluding
and Trump is like wins I got this guy
from New York I came in I actually want
to make this country better
I cut I'm like my own man I know I'm
gonna tick you off but I actually want
America to thrive and be prosperous and
really well well thought of people who
are smart people are throwing the word
treason traitor the guy should be in
handcuffs he should be let out of the
Oval Office
all of these people tonight should look
at themselves in the mirror and think
maybe I need to re-examine how I speak
on these issues in the future not that
we don't all make mistakes we do I do
you do we all yeah I've made big
mistakes as do I but these were
pronouncements that would destroy
families
destroy presidencies and as you pointed
out early and I'm so glad you did the
lost opportunities that we might have
actually worked with countries that
could box out China on things I mean do
we really not want to work with Russia
on anything ever again because last time
I checked China
has that has the biggest threat to the
United States Russia's economy what is
the size of France's yeah Texas I mean
it's like come on it's like a pulls up
working guess Philly and China doing
military exercises and we're on the
sidelines guy okay we're just gonna we
gotta act really mean on everything with
Russia because of this smaller
investigation it had a profound policy
effect I think on our government and
that we'll never know really the effect
on the American people our geopolitical
position that must be examined and also
in the social fabric and I noticed it
here like you I'm not from Washington
but I spent my life here I know you have
to I've known you for most of that time
this city has become paranoid
distrustful angry I talk to people all
the time I can't text that to you I
don't trust my you don't trust your text
what country is this I can't have this
conversation I'm too nervous people are
afraid do you want to live in a place
where people are afraid where the
prosecution state becomes so big and so
powerful a mere accusation can turn your
life upside down
yes now Donald Trump is a lot of money
he can defend himself
that's right he happened to be innocent
of these charges he knew it all along
and everyone who said oh him he's why is
he meeting behind closed doors of the
Russians why did he put Pat Putin on the
back whatever criticism maybe it's
because he realized he had an obligation
of the American people to look past
Muller as hard as it was and actually
tried to do the right thing in the
moment for the country they never gave
him that benefit of the doubt they
deserve that benefit of the doubt and he
never got it from them what happens next
I think the left is going to go into a
into a deeper rage I think they'll learn
nothing from this sadly maybe some of
the the smarter folks like Meacham and
others well but I think now it's gonna
turn to Trento it's not transparent Barr
was brought in to be the cleanup man
here this isn't a serious review so I
think again like we're seeing on the
socialism lurch they're lurching towards
social socialism slouching towards
socialism I think in this case they're
gonna be in a very precarious position
with the internal anger from the
activists who thought you know we
finally got we thought you got the
roadrunner we finally cut wildly TNT we
like she's like gone again this time
you're gonna freak I mean I think
they're gonna freak and I don't think
much is gonna change but it's gonna mean
they're gonna move more radical on the
policy front and try to whip up more
enthusiasm that way I don't see what
else they do I mean to put all their
hope on the southern district are we
gonna go back to that now Southern
District of New York which is
grotesquely poor yeah so you are on in
one hour
six minutes we have Joe digenova
we have Ken Starr we have Robert ray
both independent counsel yes course and
we Byron York's and look at the media
angle we're gonna be great great show so
we're looking forward to IB and Devin
Nunez it's gonna sitting in my living
room with a Perrier watch as I do every
night well it's great to soccer it's
always going to be much anytime